[Music]
we once again return to part four of the
heroes path
a seven-part mini-series covering the
various journeys of the most important
characters
while embroiled in the chaos that was
the great calamity
if you haven't already be sure to check
out the previous parts and especially
the one about link and zelda
since the later episodes skip over most
of the introduction established in that
one
and start right away at the moment of
ganon's rise
joining me today all the way from the
fifth dimension
the master of hype mr hmk
i am very excited to finally have him on
the channel
be sure to check out his amazing
theories as well as his podcast the
fifth dimension
in which he invites various guests to
talk about specific games
one of which recently hosted a plethora
of zelda theorists including me to sit
down and talk
about the upcoming hyrule warriors age
of calamity
and let me tell you the hype is real
and now it is time to get this show on
the road
once again
as the ground begins to shake beneath
the feet of the champions and the
princess and the sky begins to glow in
ominous red color ravali takes flight
to investigate the commotion to his
shock he sees the center point
of the hilaine civilization being
enveloped in a whirlpool of dark clouds
lightning and a ghostly specter soaring
above the peaks
of the majestic hyrule castle he reports
his findings to the rest of the group
and after discussing a strategy he and
the rest of the party
take to the road or in rivalli's case
the skies
blessed with the advantage of wounded
flight ravali soars upwards to start his
journey
towards valmetto located in rito village
within the hebrew province in terms of
distance his divine beast is
actually the furthest from the promenade
however without the hurdles of having to
scale mountains and stick to the roads
his path leading to his ancient machine
is by far the easiest
unless he had some company along the way
something we'll get into shortly
now we don't know exactly how fast
rivali is
but it's safe to say that with his
advantage of being able to fly
he will likely be one of the first if
not the first to reach his divine beast
with mifa being a possible contender
since varuta is by far the closest to
the promenade
with such a straightforward path you
would expect rivali's journey to be the
most boring and unnecessary one to
depict through gameplay
and there is a possibility that his road
to valmero
will simply not be included as a
gameplay section
but let's spice it up a bit and sketch
some awesome
yet very speculative scenarios age of
calamity could potentially use
to make rivals journey more interesting
starting with
aerial battles although ravali's path is
depicted as a straightforward one in
creating a champion
one thing that catches the attention is
the fact that he actually flies right
past hyrule castle and even slightly
over the west side of castletown
so what if ravali's weight of our meadow
is hindered by flying enemies
the first of which would come to mind of
course being the guardian skywatcher
the flying battleship variant of the
grounded guardian stalker
this way a path that looks like this
would suddenly transform into something
like this
if the engine of hyrule warriors permits
it aerial combat would definitely spice
up the gameplay
it could make rivalli's missions the
most unique out of all the champions and
would complement his overall skill set
as a master of the bow
we did see a very short clip of rivali
engaging grounded enemies
but in my opinion a weapon like the bow
doesn't reach the same potential as
melee weapons or magic while grounded
since you would have to deal with draw
speed precise aiming and a limited
attack radius
so unless rivali all of a sudden uses
melee attacks as well
something we haven't seen him do at any
point in any of the cutscenes and as far
as we know isn't part of his skill set
there needs to be a different way of
making his combat more interesting hence
fights with flying enemies
there is one possible inconsistency
though and that is that it's not exactly
clear if the guardian skywatchers will
already be present at the castle at the
time ravali is in its vicinity
according to the backstory of breath of
the wild the sky watchers were not part
of the mechanical army the hylians dug
up right before the calamity
as zelda hypothesizes in her research
notes that there are potentially more
guardian
types stored inside the five columns
hidden underneath hyrule castle
if that is indeed where the sky watches
are stored the columns would have to
have risen up by the time rivali reaches
castle town
something we aren't sure of as of right
now and it's still up for debate
whatever the case may be age of calamity
might have to change this part of the
lore to make this work
something i am totally fine with if it
makes for more interesting gameplay
alternatively rivali could come under
attack by other types of flying or
floating enemies
like swarms of keys cursed enemies sky
octorocks or
maybe even wiz ropes could reach these
heights i mean they do float after all
after possibly having fought his way
past central hyrule from up high
revali enters the hebrew region there
are two significant sentiments which
could be used as the stage
for a grounded gameplay section for
rivali that being tabitha village
and his hometown retail village if
aerial combat is not going to be a thing
we might see revali
visit one or both of these settlements
to help fend off
a possible invasion the guardian
stalkers
will in all likelihood not play a role
in this
due to its secluded location tabantha
village wasn't attacked by the guardians
until later stages of the calamity and
rito village
was spared this fate all together by the
time the guardians were getting close to
the home of the rito
zelda sealed calamity ganon after which
he lost
most direct control of his mechanical
army
so in this case these invasions or
attacks would have to be related to
monsters
ravali isn't exactly the most selfless
character
but even if he doesn't care much for the
fate of tabitha village he would
at the very least not leave his own
people to fend off for themselves
if retail village is under monster
attack he would in all probability
join the battle to ensure the safety of
his tribe and then move on to his divine
beast as soon as things are under
control
vamero is located pretty much at retail
village
so from there it's a straight shot to
its final destination
with that said the next scenario is one
we haven't discussed so far in the
series
and was purposely saved for this episode
if all previous scenarios
don't come to fruition there is yet
another way
to really make rival's journey very
interesting
since what if we actually get to control
the meadow for a while what other divine
beasts
this is a bit harder to imagine since
they would have to interact with the
complex geography of hyrule
like mountains rivers and valleys since
valmetto is airborne
this really isn't too much of a stretch
on top of that
rivali's war machine isn't just armed
with a giant laser which will probably
just be overkill against smaller enemies
but it's also equipped with bow cannons
perhaps
we could switch between these different
cannons and blast incoming enemies out
of the sky
by this point the giant pillars
surrounding hyrule castle
most definitely would have risen so sky
watchers are now
guaranteed to be flying around as soon
as ravali gets vamedo into position to
take aim at calamity ganon himself
the demon king uses his malice to
corrupt the divine beast
turning it from friend to foe ravali is
faced with one of ganon's horrific
phantoms which has now deemed itself the
new master of the ancient machine
a fight ensues between dorito warrior
and wind blight ganon
a fight which determines the fate of the
many inhabitants of hyrule since the
destructive power of valmeado
would be any settlement's worst
nightmare after a fierce battle
rivali is eventually bested by his
opponent and falls to the hands of the
merciless phantom
he suffers the same fate as the other
champions with his spirit now trapped
inside the technological prowess
he worked so hard for to master but all
was not
for nothing despite losing the fight and
thus his life to win blight canon he
managed to keep up the fight long enough
so that valmetto was never to be used
against his allies
with the power to vaporize entire cities
with ease it would have been
unimaginable what could have happened
had rivali not been there to hold of his
nemesis for as long as he did
with the shortest lifespan of all of
hyrule's races
no rito present at the time of breath of
the wild was alive at the time of
rivali's passing
however his memory is passed on among
his tribe
and their children are raised to be
brave and skilled like their legendary
ancestor
as for rivali himself he will eventually
get his sweet revenge
due to the efforts of what was once his
biggest rival from 100 years ago
[Music]
you